[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alle der presse gleich
werden wir erfahren ob meine geschichte
stimmt in der zwischenzeit schauen wir
auf das wort lügen center in deutschland
weiß 2014 das unwort des jahres
anhänger von veba und der
rechtspopulistischen asc setzen damit
gegen alle jene medien die ihre
ansichten nicht teilen
nun hat ein prominenter vertreter dieser
sogenannten lügen fläche dieses buch
geschrieben gebrauchsanweisung für
populisten heribert prantl wehrt sich
damit gegen vereinfachungen und
populistischen auftritte von rechts
[Musik]
man darf die lügen und den haft nicht
weiter trennen lassen
man muss sie zu löschen versuchten
einsatz wie eine aufforderung typisch
für dieses buch für diese kampfschrift
ehre wert prantl der streitbare
journalist der süddeutschen zeitung
verfasst hat ein pamphlet gegen die
unkultur des gegen die politik der
unwahrheit und f ressentiments
der titel ist verblüffend ja er verwirft
gebrauchsanweisung für populisten oder
hinter dem fifa steht auch der aha
effekt oder der verdutzt zeigen wie
brandl schreibt für populisten wenn ich
den titel genau diese und die ersten
seiten gelesen habe dann bei sich oder
dann weiß man was ich sagen soll
eine gebrauchsanweisung wie man mit
populisten umgehen muss mit populisten
meinte panther- politische extremisten
vom rechten rand die deutsche afd
marine le pens von nationalrat wilders
freiheitspartei die österreichische fpm
allesamt ultranationalistische und
antieuropäisch und meine eigenen
gedanken begann damit dass ich mich
fragte mensch prantl was hast du denn
selber in den vergangenen 25 jahren bei
dem du politik schreibst und politik
begleitet durch populismus bezeichnet
und ich muss ein bisschen feld kritisch
sagen vielleicht waren wir in der
qualifizierung von politik als
populistisch
ein bisschen zu groß oder zu unpräzis
er bat brannte spart nicht mit kritik am
gegenwärtigen politischen diskurs in dem
der begriff populismus vielleicht zu
schnell so oft und so unspezifisch
verwendet wird ich habe das gefühl wenn
wir jetzt von rechtspopulismus riesen
der gebrauchten begriff der weko mit war
vor allem der verpufft wenn lügen und
falsche behauptungen die politische
landschaft bestimmen
auch wenn die längst widerlegte medien
also und auch mir vorwerfe ist wir haben
den sogenannten rechtspopulismus in
deutschland kfd eine über aufmerksamkeit
geschenkt wir haben sie körper gemacht
sind und über aufmerksamkeit schafft
über bedeutung und die über bedeutung
hat sich dann auch im wahlergebnissen
wider gespiegelt
doch rechtspopulisten beherrschen das
feilschen um aufmerksamkeit perfekt
provokation um der provokation willen
ausgrenzen nach unten treten sündenböcke
suchen und mit hass politik machen
man hat absurditäten ernst genommen und
wir haben phänomene erlebt wie du sie
jetzt bei trump in amerika erleben dass
wenn lügen einfach nur ständig
wiederholt werden richtet diese ständig
wiederholte lüge etwas im bewusstsein
der menschen an gesetzlich fest
dem setzt herbert fandel seine
gebrauchsanweisung entgegen
er will dass die politik in einer
globalisierten welt reale perspektiven
bietet er will dass die menschen heimat
finden in einer liberalen gesellschaft
dafür soll leidenschaftlich gekämpft
werden durch auf mit populistischen
mitteln mit einer politik wie gestaltet
und verstanden wird und den menschen die
sie betrifft
es gibt einen demokratischen populismus
der wichtige und notwendige ich muss in
der lage sein sein eintreten für
demokratie für rechtsstaatlichkeit für
grundrechte so vorzutragen dass die
leute begeistert und die leute müssen
meine eigene begeisterung spüren der
verlogenen propaganda leidenschaftlich
wahrheiten entgegenschleudern vielleicht
auch ein auftrag an die vermeintliche
lügen presse
ja wenn auch der politischen ebene
gelogen wird dann ist das keine